tested three off the mark deflected
the scanner anderson with a save goes
crashing over the score stable curry for
three
it's good steph curry from downtown
viscono anderson still has not gotten up
they want a foul to stop the clock and
there it is
and everybody running over
and anderson is down an amazing
effort from juan toscano anderson but
when crashing over that scores table to
save it
[Applause]
you mentioned about curry being tough
this young man super tough as well mark
he's fearless you hate to see all the
attention being paid to him hopefully
he's all right
[Applause]
typical play by this young man just all
out hustle
[Applause]
you know under normal circumstances with
the scores table like that it's usually
everybody's right next to each other and
sometimes that breaks the fall
one thing to look at look at the monitor
monitor after he falls falls behind him
hopefully he's okay
but clearly in some pain and still down
you see almost the entire team
over there checking on their warrior
[Applause]
brother
hurry trying to loosen up the ankle
jimmy capers also over there
as we said earlier this young man has
been just a tremendous story
and obviously a little wobbly after that
young man from east oakland getting a
huge ovation here
from about 2300 fans
in attendance
[Applause]
with a good career at marquette and then
as we said took them five years to get
to the nba
five years of hard work said there were
times we thought about
might not work but he has become a big
part of their rotation one